Hello everyone, it's monthly mailbag time
again and today we dive into the world
of chemistry to look at some really
interesting elements in compounds
One of my colleagues at one point when we were
trying to convince the people in Sudbury
that this was a benign safe experiment
that went to the City Council and drank
a glass of heavy water to show that it's
non radioactive and perfectly safe of
course he as he was drinking it he
poured a little bit of whiskey in and
said nothing improves the taste of heavy
water like a little bit of teachers but
that's that possum per day was surprised
by the story of someone having drunk a
whole glass of heavy water yes is it
dangerous as well as expensive now heavy
water sounds scary but it's actually not
that dangerous hydrogen is the simplest
atom in the universe it's just a proton
with one electron orbiting in it but
sometimes a neutron gets squeezed in
there making a heavy version of hydrogen
called deuterium about one in every six
thousand hydrogen atoms in the world is
deuterium and it forms quite naturally
in very rare cases though another
neutron can wedge its way in there to
make tritium that's very unstable and so
that second Neutron will pop out again
that means tritium is radioactive you
can make molecules like water with these
special forms of hydrogen and since the
deuterium is heavier than normal
hydrogen we call the water made with
deuterium heavy water
here's the thing though the mass of a
water molecule is dominated by the
oxygen even if you double the weight of
the both of the hydrogen using deuterium
the overall mass will only be about 11%
higher so most of its properties are
pretty similar but biological systems
are very sensitive to even tiny
differences so in large doses heavy
water can destruct enzymes and stop cell
division most guidelines say you need to
replace about half of the water in your
body with heavy water to feel any
negative effects so one glass won't hurt
all gone freezes at about minus 190
degrees centigrade and boils about minus
under 97 or something like that so it
has a very narrow liquid phase so within
three degrees ago to being a solid to
being a gas weld your William at welding
wouldn't be possible with it are gone
but what other uses does it have argon
is a extremely inert be fairly common
see fairly cheap and easy to produce
Indy a terrible heat conductor these
characteristics make it perfect for a
number
different applications its use loads and
industrial processes to make sure oxygen
or other gases can't get close to the
important reactions this is what makes
it so good for welding it also has some
unexpected applications for example in
fire extinguishers for server rooms and
in other places with delicate equipment
it's much harder to freeze argon than it
is to pre co2 so it's great if you don't
want dry ice building up on wires it's
also used as a preservative most often
this is for food or for wine but it's
also used to preserve important
documents like the American Declaration
of Independence that you see magenta
absolutely beautiful and that's why you
don't see magenta in the spectrum you
don't see magenta in the rain book
because it doesn't have a wavelength and
to finish things off a bird question
checky asked if magenta is not a
wavelength of light does that mean that
flamingos have red and blue pigment in
their feathers so first off flamingos
are born grey and they actually turn
pink over time because of the way they
break down the proteins in their diet
the third they eat mostly shrimp and
algae contain lots of carotenoids fat
soluble orange and red pigments but the
carotenoids are locked up with other
molecules that make them reflect blue or
gray hence why is shrimp analogy don't
look bright pink when they're alive the
birds digestive system then strips the
carotenoids and deposits them without
their original molecular casings in the
feathers resulting in that bright pink
coloration you're familiar with you can
simulate the effective of flamingos
digestive system with heat just put the
lobster some shrimp in a pot and they'll
turn bright red when you cook them
that's all for me today keep those
questions coming and I'll see you next
time
you